chaque année en papouasie nouvelle
guinée des centaines de personnes
principalement des femmes sont accusées
de sorcellerie
ils sont torturés sur la place publique
les cas de torture seraient en hausse
mais les ressources pour intervenir
elles sont nettement insuffisantes
notamment nos goûts nos propres aux bus
no right on se trouve dans les hautes
terres en compagnie d'anthony c'est un
fils de missionnaires américains qui
habite ici depuis l'âge de 5 ans il
consacre une grande partie de son temps
à combattre les violences liées aux
accusations de sorcellerie
il va nous aider à comprendre ce qui se
passe
des images du meurtre de cette femme de
20 ans 2013 ont fait le tour du monde et
elles ont provoqué l'indignation de la
communauté internationale le
gouvernement à modifier ses lois pour
mieux protéger les victimes a rétabli la
peine de mort pour les agresseurs mais
sept ans plus tard les cas de torture se
multiplient et ils apparaissent même
dans des régions du pays qui
traditionnellement n'avait pas ce
problème là la papouasie nouvelle guinée
est un pays très complexe
il compte plus de 8 millions d'habitants
on y parle plus de 800 langues
autochtones
il ya des milliers de clans autant de
croyances et de superstition bien que la
population soit majoritairement
chrétienne ici beaucoup de gens croient
ce qu'on appelle sangouma sangouma c'est
une force ou encore un esprits
surnaturels qui peut provoquer toutes
sortes d'événements malheureux la
définition de sangomar varie énormément
d'une province à l'autre
l'une des croyances les plus répandue
est que lorsque les femmes sont possédés
par son goût mais elles peuvent voler ou
manger le coeur des gens on les accuse
alors de causer des accidents la maladie
et même la mort 2
les cas de torture ont commencé à
apparaître
il ya environ cinq ans dans la province
web et anton ça l'a poussé à développer
des programmes de sensibilisation entre
autres dans les écoles mais son
implication on va beaucoup plus loin
il doit parfois directement secourir des
victimes
[Musique]
une des personnes qu'il a aidé ces
mariages est une femme de 38 ans mère de
quatre enfants a été accusée de
sorcellerie en 2016 par les membres de
sa communauté à l'intérieur de son
propre village
elle a été torturée et la raison bien
c'est parce qu'il ya un jeune homme dans
sa communauté qui a perdu connaissance
alors les gens de son village ont accusé
de sorcellerie elle a été torturée
pendant trois heures
elle accepte et nous rencontrer pour
nous livrer son témoignage
mais pour assurer sa sécurité margaret a
dû être soigné dans une autre province
où personne ne la connaît souvent les
victimes sont en danger lorsqu'ils sont
traitées dans un hôpital local
les croyances engouement ça va jusqu'à
affecter la qualité des soins
anton nous amène maintenant dans une
province voisine sim bout ou là les
accusations de sorcellerie font partie
des traditions depuis beaucoup plus
longtemps
plusieurs accords même que les croyances
engouement sont nés ici pour ensuite se
répandre ailleurs au pays
montilien la personne qu'on cherche à
rencontrer c'est clara repas une des
collaboratrices dalton on a dû quitter
l'endroit où il est beaucoup de gens
pour aller faire l'entrevue parce que
c'est un sujet que le ce sens il ne
travaille pour une organisation qui a
aidé les femmes qui ont été torturés en
lien avec de la sauce avec pratiquement
aucune ressource
clara accueil des victimes dans sa
propre maison et ça depuis des années
2000 2002 locaux oui in terris libye
[Musique]
eroglu a levé les deux ans et demi à
billy beane sans limite
[Musique]
devant l'augmentation dès violences
liées aux accusations de sorcellerie
cet inspecteur a mis sur pied en 2015 un
bureau qui est spécialisé dans le
traitement de ces cas mais malgré ces
efforts les ressources à sa disposition
sont extrêmement limités pour le musée
des beaux arts au pis tous les accords
et compromis difficiles de la police
michael we were in der wissel rabat où
tout lui en d'autres mains olga tanon
malak al zor est debout readers and fall
et riesling
je me sens même si l'inspecteur neely a
réussi à arrêter des agresseurs aucun
d'entre eux n'a été condamné c'est
difficile d'avoir un vrai portrait de la
situation et de connaître le nombre
exact de victimes à l'échelle nationale
nintendo
antonia méchant des journalistes pour la
télévision d'état pour ses collègues et
elle c'est loin d'être évident de
rapporter les cas de torture deux mois
avant notre passage
trois femmes ont été brûlées vives près
d'ici mais ça a été impossible pour
antonia de couvrir l'événement
en tout cas pas prévue si tout le proto
lettre au ministre pour une session live
distance après son exil de près de deux
ans margaret a finalement pu revenir
dans son village
lorsqu'on l'a rencontrée et elle était
de retour chez elle depuis à peine trois
semaines elle côtoie à nouveau ses
agresseurs qui eux n'ont jamais fait
face à la justice
une cérémonie qui a réuni tout le
village a permis de finaliser son retour
anton était la cérémonie
[Musique]
m